you know what talking is no this is on
the rocks with Jimmy rock stars tonight
we've got recklesstortuga Eric Jason and
Tommy five fingers up never have I ever
fantasized about a video game character
oh god I'm not to mater yeah oh yeah to
my definite you might say I never oh
love you no not those Lord croc titties
are amazing those pix elated titties
were some words just her voice when
she's like shimmy to the net as a 13
year old that's all I needed exactly
never have I ever read a graphic novel
oh I'm definitely not a [ __ ] nerd but
no yes you have no that's a dimension hi
no no wait you got the cartoon
compilation graphic novel there's a
cartoon compilation can we take a vote
it's like that's a graphic no a college
McConville agents are graphic novel what
do you think a [ __ ] graphic novel is
you it's a [ __ ] full more of it like
[ __ ] Oh what do you think washington
city is not sin city yes its individual
issues that are then compiled into a
great man so I think lower finger [ __ ]
you never have I ever went skydiving
never done it yeah neither have I know
it is I think it's gonna throw an idiot
I never [ __ ] sky night all right well
I hate to fly why would I [ __ ] go to
play the jump out of it
I don't want me to film it well I don't
understand what [ __ ] is the stupidest
thing never ever ever had stitches no
I've never hang out another scam have
fun guys how did you get stitches my
brother Mikey we were at the town pool
and he's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and he
pushed me into the pool I turn around
really fast to you it was and I hit my
chin on the side of the pool and just
blew it open yeah at a scarf never have
I ever cosplayed in public no I've never
done that what do we look like losers
excuse me you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] we
filmed sketches at comic-con what are
you wearing did you look like Frodo
Buckland ask sticks and stones Dark
Elves that's not cosplay you were
dressed up as the online gamer what a
bunch of losers that is not God way I've
cosplay so I've got double out I've
never jerked off with my left hand mmm
okay ah probably I mean I've done more
weird [ __ ] than that that hotel in my
mind I'm like I definitely imagine being
like we drive up I I never want like if
I have no answer that experience I want
it to be perfect at that time that's the
double stranger go to the left hand and
you fall asleep on it no the stalefish
is right did you go up under the leg try
anything no question they'll get to
white people at 0 never have I ever had
frosted tips no I'm the Red Cross
intensity on that I wasn't I was a young
man and Dawson's Creek was oh yeah hey
she had old and I started that didn't
make it cool all right all right now I
got to figure out how to get a black
person out because you're working went
out making this a race war yeah how can
I do it never have I ever ordered fried
chicken at a restaurant well that's a
[ __ ] racist I've never done it I've
had for second with you we've gone to
roscoes together Eric put it down put it
down I woulda said I wish that I wasn't
genetically
to like [ __ ] alicious delicious never
have I ever had a casserole I wish I
should have said that castor you've got
a castrato feel like I'm you jelly once
you have your white yeah well I guess I
win yes I win I honestly think he's full
of [ __ ] never ordered fried chicken when
you win at never ever you really lose it
means you haven't lived a life so Jason
actually lost well Cheers